from professional Heroes and dangerous
villains to just straight up monsters
and beasts these are 20 of the strongest
characters in my hero Academia number 20
tokoyami fumikage tokoyami is one of the
few students in class 1a who has
exhibiting great strength from the
beginning and has only improved over
time by far his biggest strength lies in
his Quirk Dark Shadow this Quirk allows
him to manifest a sentient shadow
monster from his body that he can
control when Dark Shadow is summoned in
dark conditions its powered gross
exponentially to the point where he
himself can't control it at this time
the shadow is powerful enough to defeat
some of the strongest villains instantly
additionally he also uses the technique
to envelop his body with Shadow and
channel the power into his fists
allowing him to deal even more damage
with these outstanding skills tokoyami
surely deserves his spot on the list
okay let's switch it up a bit and cover
a villain next and a very bad one at
that Kai Chi saki overhaul is a very
dangerous villain and the main
antagonist of the Shia hasakay Arc his
Quirk lets him disassemble him
reassemble anything he touches including
people this means that the ability can
be used to either hurt people by taking
them apart or heal people by putting
them back together we saw just how
strong overhaul is in his fight against
Deku where the young hero had no chance
of defeating him it was only when Deku
used full Cal at 100 with Aries help
that the villain was finally brought
down the fact that he managed to battle
against this form of Deku along with his
experience and Powers should easily put
him above tokoyami number 18. mitiko
mitico has the abilities of a rabbit
giving her incredible length strength
with which she can jump around quickly
and kick opponents with extreme force in
fact it wouldn't be an exaggeration to
say that she's one of the strongest
heroes in terms of physical strength man
just imagine before she could hit the
Subscribe button with she would
absolutely destroy it and you should too
okay don't really destroy it a gentle
click with your mouse should be enough
thanks anyway miriko proved her mic
during the Paranormal Liberation War
where she effortlessly took down various
nomu and even assisted in the final
battle against shigaraki despite her
injuries given Miracle Superior standing
among professional Heroes and her
impressive performance throughout the
series I believe she deserves a higher
position on the list than toke Yami in
overhaul alright I noticed in analytics
that over 50 percent of people watch my
videos on their phone and if you're one
of those people I have an irresistible
offer for you raid Shadow Legends the
sponsor of today's video okay so I know
all of you have heard about rain so my
question is why the heck are you not
playing it well I made a list of three
reasons why you absolutely have to give
it a shot firstly the champion designs
are amazing check out this one it has
the shadow abilities like tokayani or
this one who has flame abilities like
Endeavor next I can change the language
to Japanese so it feels like I'm playing
an anime game and lastly it has so many
cool bosses just look at this scary
dragon or this giant bat I really want
to defeat them at some point there's
currently a valentine event going on
with bonuses for all new players just
download the game using my link copy
your player ID and paste it on this
website you can then play one of the
mini games and get some amazing in-game
and real-life prizes like Valentine's
Day themed Champs and even Amazon gift
cards worth up to one thousand dollars
and if you're an old player don't worry
everyone can use code St valentine23 to
get a small gift if you haven't started
playing raid yet click my link in the
description or scan my QR code here on
the screen you'll get unique bonuses
worth thirty dollars including free epic
champion shinodu and other useful stuff
number 17 best genist best genus is an
excellent example of why sheer raw
strength isn't the only thing that makes
you a Pro Hero he's currently a number
three professional hero and his unique
Quirk fiber Master allows him to
manipulate fibers of clothes as he wills
at first this Quirk may not seem that
impressive but due to all the training
he's done over the years it allows him
to manipulate fibers in ways you
wouldn't even think of usually best
genus uses his Quirk to form safety nets
to protect people from harm or to buying
these foes however if he wants to be
more aggressive he can also wrap the
threads around his opponent's neck and
attempt to suffocate them his most
impressive feat is restraining
gigantabakia a being with immeasurable
strength that's virtually impossible to
subdue everything best genus has shown
so far in the manga is enough to earn
him the 17th spot on the list number 16
Hawks Hawks the number two pro hero
shows us that intelligence can sometimes
be far more useful than raw strength he
has big feathery wings that let him fly
but can also be used offensively for
example Hawks can telekinetically
control his feathers making them sharp
and hard increasing their speed
considerably the most amazing thing
about his feathers is that he can use
the bakari things which helped him
evacuate a bunch of citizens from the
collapsing Skyscraper with his
remarkable speed strong feathers and
Keen intelligence Hawks can beat even
some of the strongest villains in the
series although he doesn't have the raw
power of Heroes like nidiko Hawk's
abilities are far more versatile and can
be used in pretty much any situation
considering this and the fact that he's
the youngest pro hero to ever reach a
rank this high he should be able to
defeat niriko and best genus in battle
number 15. lady Nagant the former pro
hero and Hawk senior lady Nagant is a
powerful combatant that joined the dark
side due to the horrible Mission she was
tasked to do lady nagant's rifle quick
lets her extend a rifle from her elbow
and create a scope and different types
of bullets her second Quirk helps her
with Mobility allowing her to float in
midair which further helps her in fights
she is considered to be the best
long-range fighter in the country even
snipe a strong Pro Hero with a quirk
that improves his ranged attacks admits
that he can't hope to compete with her
as she far outclasses his Quirk with raw
skill alone wow imagine being called
snipe and still having no shot against
it yeah okay I'll stop with the jokes
now although the fight between lady
nagan and Hawks would surely be really
interesting due to her years of
experience I think she'd emerge
Victorious number 14 high-end nomu nomus
are artificially made humans that are
heavily modified using the bodies of
deceased people the higher end nomus
like Hood have an unimaginable amount of
strength and wield multiple quirks the
high end nomu can easily overpower some
of the strongest Pro Heroes like best
genus and even Endeavor face to tough
time defeating it as the Nomi was far
more robust than anything he'd ever
encountered from Super regeneration to
enormous physical power these beings are
literally made for combat and I don't
think any of the previous characters on
this list had any chance of defeating
one number 13. Dobby Dobby the oldest
child of endeavor is one of the major
antagonists throughout the series he's
proficient in using his scorching blue
flames which can burn anything to a
crisp the interesting thing about Dobby
is that he doesn't have a high
resistance to heat instead he trained
his body to be completely insensitive to
pain in order to use his Quirk freely
Dobby's done some really impressive
things throughout the series like
fighting on par with a kitten repelling
bakugan's escort Squad and even
completely overpowering Hogs Japan's
number two hero additionally Dobby
learned Flashfire Fist from his father
the strongest flame type technique this
ability allows the user to raise the
temperature of his Flames to the highest
levels and with Dobby's Quirk the attack
deals even more devastating damage than
ever before although Dobby is incredibly
strong he's actually the weakest member
of his family on this list so let's
continue with his brother Shoto Shoto
showcases his strength enters UA high
and becomes one of the strongest
students in class 1a although Shoto has
one Quirk it's split into two parts
giving him two different abilities ice
and fire Shoto initially used only his
eyesight due to hatred towards his
father but eventually started using his
Fireside as well which significantly
increased his power later in the show he
developed a technique called phosphorus
which lets him merge Fire and Ice
together and perform much stronger
attacks than before this ability even
allowed him to overpower Dobby's blue
flames and eventually win their recent
fight based on this Shoto deserves to be
placed higher than Dobby and other
characters on this list next up is
another major antagonist rodestro the
grand commander of the meta Liberation
Army we got a taste of his strength in
his fight against the league of villains
where he effortlessly defeats twice by
activating his Quirk with just one
finger however rudestro's fight against
shigaraki was an actual depiction of his
true string his stress Quirk allows the
villain to store any negative emotion
and convert it into raw strength
significantly increasing his size in his
stress state rodestro's power is
unmatched and one swing of his arm can
generate a massive shock wave moreover
with his claustro suit rodestro's stress
further increases to 150 percent
increasing his strength to a frightening
level the guy undoubtedly deserves a
high spot on the list as he even gave
shikiraki a tough time alright we're
only halfway done with the list and the
characters are already this powerful can
you imagine that there's still 10 more
characters stronger than these well
there are and one of them is usj nomu
undeniably the usj nomu is one of the
strongest artificial humans seen in the
series he managed to single-handedly
defeat a Pro Hero like Eraserhead with
absolute ease moreover it was made to
counter all might and possesses the
power and speed that Rivals his it
either managed to Gravely injury him
during the battle showcasing that its
abilities were no joke additionally it
possesses two quirks super regeneration
and shock absorption making it a
humanoid punching bag that takes
literally no damage while verdestro's
Quirk can make him really powerful he'd
find it very hard to surpass usj nomu in
speed and physical strength therefore it
deserves 10th place on the list number
nine bakugou since the beginning bakugou
had a strong grasp on his Quirk often
using it for full-on offense during
battles his explosion Quirk makes him
sweat nitroglycerin from his palms which
he uses to create well explosions due to
his overall strength and proficiency
with the Quirk even the league of
villains wanted him to join their
organization by the time of the
Paranormal Liberation Arc bakugou became
really versatile in using the Quirk
propelling himself in the air to dodge
attacks while also attacking his
opponent simultaneously what's truly
surprising is that during the final war
bakugo's strength had increased to the
point that even shikiraki was feeling
nervous his ultimate technique cluster
increased his power even further helping
him deal damage to shiguraki and making
him Panic if bakugou can make shigaraki
Panic then the usj nomu shouldn't be a
problem for him okay make way for the
next character and I mean really make
way since the next character is the 100
foot tall bodyguard of all for one
giganto Maki yeah during the Paranormal
Liberation War machia perfectly
exhibited his powers showcasing how
countless Pro Heroes were no match for
him he has everything needed to be the
perfect Bodyguard from quirks that
provide him high endurance and
heightened senses to powers that make
him immune to all pain and if that's not
enough he can also increase his size
strengthen his muscles and grow Claws
from his hands the guy even easily
picked up Mount lady and threw her like
it was nothing bakugo's Quirk
undoubtedly offers him great destructive
power but he simply wouldn't be enough
to bring down this Beast even Endeavor
struggled to defeat him and multiple Pro
Heroes were required to hold him down
machia without I doubt can overpower all
characters on the list so far number
seven Endeavor endeavored the flame hero
is the current number one pro hero with
the highest number of resolved crime
cases although he might not be at the
level of all night Endeavor should not
be underestimated at any cost is Hell
flame Quirk allows him to produce and
manipulate large amounts of extremely
intense fire it will additionally due to
all the experiences player of the years
he's incredibly proficient in handling
this court using it to defeat some of
the absolutely strongest villains in the
ends in the series The this was best
shown when he used his most powerful
attack prominence burn to finally put an
end to high-end nomu although Endeavor
wouldn't have been able to defeat
giganto Makia without the help of other
Heroes it's important to mention that it
was due to the unique circumstances he
faced from realizing Dobby's true
identity therefore if he was in his full
power I think he would have been able to
defeat the Beast number six nine nine is
the primary antagonist of the my hero
Academia Movie heroes rising and is a
frighteningly powerful opponent even his
Quirk is incredibly strong granting him
control over the weather and allowing
him to cause powerful thunderstorms and
tornadoes it was so powerful in fact
that nine stated that the Quirk was
destroying his body later on 9 obtained
a weaker version of All For One and
gathered five additional quirks to Adam
in battle he demonstrated the extent of
his powers during the movie multiple
times and at the end it took two one for
all users to finally bring him down I
mean standing your own against Deku at
100 is already a great achievement but
imagine battling another guy who also
uses the Quirk at 100 Man 9 definitely
earned his place on this list only 5
five more characters are left and the
next one is America's number one hero
star and Stripes starring Stripes is
possibly the strongest female Pro Hero
in the series with even all for one
recognizing her as the strongest woman
around with her Quirk and New Order she
can set a rule on anything she touches
by calling its name allowing her to
manipulate and bestow new properties
onto herself in the world around her
okay I know this is a bit confusing but
she can literally just touch herself and
say something like I will be five times
faster and that'll literally happen yeah
it sounds way overpowered but there are
limits to it for example it stated that
evoing using her Quirk at its full power
she's still nowhere close to all night's
level of strain nevertheless this Quirk
should be more than enough to bring down
all the previous characters on this list
without any trouble number four all for
one the once most powerful villain in
the series in the symbol of evil all for
one is the league of villains founder
and is a natural Nemesis of anyone who
wields the one for all Quirk what makes
all for one powerful is his Quirk which
allows him to steal the quirks of others
he can then either keep the stolen Quirk
for himself or pass it on to someone
else he's been alive for a very long
time and throughout the years he's
stolen hundreds of incredibly strong
quirks making himself pretty much
Invincible all for one was unshakable in
his prime and effortlessly defeated many
pro Heroes that were in his way
including many of the previous one for
all the users although we don't know all
the exact quirks this guy has I think
it's safe to say that he's prepared for
pretty much any situation based on this
if he ever battled star and Stripes he
would certainly be ready to counter her
quirk in some way and defeat the hero
number three all might the symbol of
peace all night is regarded as the
strongest Pro Hero ever with unmatched
levels of strength he single-handedly
brought stability to Japan and many
villains were scared and discouraged by
his appearance however what really shows
his strength is that he was able to
defeat All For One his arch nemesis was
known as the most powerful villain in
the world this is obviously no small
feat as none of the previous one for all
users could defeat this guy not even
close also another important thing to
mention is that even at the very
beginning of the show all night was
already past his prime today aging
injuries just imagine how strong he was
when he was younger it's literally
inconceivable I don't think there's any
additional explanation needed all might
would easily Crush anyone on the list so
far and deserves the third spot before
we cover the absolutely strongest
character on the list let's first cover
the second strongest shigaraki as the
league of villains leader shigaraki has
always been exceptionally strong due to
his Decay Quirk that disintegrates
everything he touches with his hand
during his battle with frodastro his
powers reached a terrifying State when
he had a Reawakening allowing him to
deteriorate anything using only one
finger to further add to the dread
shigaraki's body was modified by Dr
garaki which significantly increased his
physical abilities and made his Decay
Quirk even more powerful like that
wasn't enough he also inherited one for
all and several other quirks that came
with it at this point shikiraki can
defeat any Pro Hero that comes his way
no matter how powerful they are he
proved this by defeating America's
number one hero starring Stripes
relatively quickly despite a
ridiculously powerful Quirk based on his
performance during the Paranormal
Liberation War it was obvious that
shigaraki surpassed his former master
all for one and with that I think he
deserves the title of second strongest
character in the entire series number
one Deku Deku is the ninth one for all
users inheriting The Quirk from his Idol
and Mentor almight in the beginning Deku
couldn't control this new power and
would get severely injured each time he
tried however with time training and
hard work he got a much better grip on
his powers and was eventually able to
use them at their maximum with one for
all at 100 Deku reaches the level of all
might and can fight toe-to-toe with
pretty much any villain in the series
what separates him from his mentor is
the ability to use all the quirks of the
previous one for all holders this means
the Deku can now use seven quirks in
total which makes him undoubtedly the
strongest one for all user ever what
supports this is that in the manga
yoyishi stated that deku's power is now
at 120 surpassing the 100 limit that was
believed to be impossible all the powers
Deku obtained from the previous users
combined with his unwavering resolve
made him the only person in the world
capable of taking on shigaraki and
saving everyone are you interested in
hearing more about Deku and his powers
click on this video where we explained
all deku's forms in my hero Academia